el tiroteo de texas ha reavivado una
disputa de larga data sobre el control
de armas en eeuu un estado abiertamente
proarmas reseñó así lo que ocurrió antes
del tiroteo de stand the information the
west no en el beat
hasta este momento la única información
que se sabía de antemano fue publicada
por el pistolero en facebook
aproximadamente 30 minutos antes de
llegar a la escuela
de forestales walsh
la primera publicación fue el punto dijo
le voy a disparar a mi abuela la segunda
publicación fue le disparé a mi abuela
la tercera publicación tal vez menos de
15 minutos antes de llegar a la escuela
decía voy a disparar en una escuela
primaria es world and win the shield en
el métrico
tras su intervención el ex congresista
demócrata del rühr que enfrentó al
gobernador acusándolo de no hacer nada
al respecto de la masacre los policías
respondieron fuertemente lo expulsaron
de la sala
tras el incidente aseguró a los
periodistas que se les debe una acción a
los padres y que es culpa de todos no
sólo de los republicanos seguir
aceptando estas acciones el presidente
estadounidense joe biden anunció su
visita a la zona
gilio viajaremos a texas en los próximos
días para reunirnos con las familias y
hacerles saber que tenemos una idea sólo
una idea de su dolor y espero llevar un
poco de consuelo a la comunidad en
estado de shock dolor y trauma
mayrén también renovó sus críticas al
lobby de las armas en eeuu que lucha
contra los intentos de imponer
regulaciones más estrictas a esta
industria la poderosa asociación
nacional del rifle culpó de la masacre a
un criminal solitario y trastornado y se
espera que el viernes se realice la
convención anual que reunirá entre otros
al ex presidente donald trump